l'onu si tous les gars du monde voulait
se donner la main disait le poète paul
fort après la terrible guerre mondiale
de 39-45 c'est un peu ce que se sont dit
les dirigeants des pays qui avaient
gagné la guerre si tous les pays du
monde
ainsi est née l'onu l'organisation des
nations unies déjà après la première
guerre mondiale qui avait été
monstrueusement meurtrière on avait dit
plus jamais ça et les chefs d'état
victorieux avait tenté de créer une
organisation qui s'appelait la société
des nations
mais ça n'avait pas marché dans cette
organisation incapable de prendre une
décision tout le monde se disputer en
1945 l'onu en a tiré les leçons
le but était d'abord de créer un lieu où
seraient réunies en permanence des
représentants de tous les pays
signataires de la charte des nations
unies
aujourd'hui près de 200 pays du plus
grand au plus petit c'est à dire
quasiment tous les pays du monde se
côtoie au siège de l'onu à new york
quand un conflit éclate entre deux pays
c'est à l'onu que l'on essaye de trouver
une solution diplomatique
si aucune solution n'est trouvée l'onu
doit prendre position et tenter
d'imposer le respect du droit
international car tous les pays membres
de l'onu doivent respecter certaines
règles comme celle de ne pas envahir le
pays voisins ou de ne pas piller les
richesses des autres
donc quand il ya un conflit entre deux
pays où même un conflit violent dans un
pays entre deux ou plusieurs parties de
la population
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu se
réunit pour prendre des décisions
le conseil de sécurité est composé des
représentants des cinq pays vainqueur de
la dernière guerre mondiale etats unis
russie grande bretagne chine et france
ce sont les membres permanents plus dix
pays qui représente tous les continents
ces dix pays tournent tous les deux ans
les 15 membres du conseil de sécurité
vote des résolutions
ce peut être des protestations des
recommandations ou des sanctions le nuc
décidé qu'on ne peut plus vendre d'armes
ou de pétrole ou tout autre chose
un pays qui aurait violé la charte des
nations unies
en envahissant son voisin ou en
bombardant son peuple qui demandaient
plus de démocratie par exemple
l'onu peut même décider de permettre à
l'armée d'un pays d'intervenir sur le
sol d'un autre pays
on dira qu'il a un mandat de l'onu pour
faire respecter le droit international
une armée formée de soldats de plusieurs
pays peut être dépêchés sur les lieux
d'un conflit pour faire respecter les
accords de cessez-le-feu
les soldats de cette armée ont des
casques bleus on les appelle d'ailleurs
les casques bleus toujours au moment où
des conflits
l'onu met en place des dispositifs pour
aider les réfugiés pour les loger les
nourrir ou les soigner d'autres agences
qui dépendent de l'onu tente de lutter
contre les famines dans les pays pauvres
de lutter contre les épidémies et
secourir les populations victimes de
catastrophes naturelles
l'onu est une sorte de pompier de la
planète mais elle n'est pas encore aussi
efficace que les vrais pompiers
parce que pour agir il faut que les pays
concernés soient d'accord tout comme
dans la proposition utopique de paul
fort que tous les hommes se donnent la
main pourtant il faudra bien y arriver
parce que les grands problèmes le
réchauffement de la planète par exemple
ne pourront se régler que par la
gouvernance mondiale